[Musique]
david elia maintenant avec la santé et
la pilule pour hommes
alors donc oui eh bien regardez bien oui
là il enverra et sûrement comprimé et 10
mois elle y prennent beaucoup plus
grosse que n'a pu pour c'est bien sûr
que nous sommes des hommes donc c'est la
pilule
il est méchant et la prison pour hommes
attention non c'est très important c'est
la première fois que nous disposons d'un
produit qui donne la contraception
masculine c'est à dire qui va empêcher
les spermatozoïdes à nous les hommes de
féconder les ovules des dames c'est une
grande première dans l'histoire de la
médecine et je suis heureux de vous en
parler
parmi l'un des premiers ce matin alors
la bulle pour hommes c'est quoi c'est un
mélange d'hormones en partie les
hormones féminines et cette hormone
féminine qui ressemble à la progestérone
va être appliquée va être donné aux
hommes chaque jour pendant tous les
gérer toute l'année de telle manière que
la spermatogénèse et à la fabrication
des spermatozoïdes ne soit plus assurer
la fermeture genève c'est un phénomène
assez compliqué il faut trois mois pour
faire des photos yd donc on comprend que
la contraception masculine et fait
l'objet de nombreuses études et qu'elle
n'arrive qu'en 1996 dans nos pharmacies
dis-moi 3 - je comprends mieux pourquoi
nous sommes tous tellement fatigués nous
les hommes cela dit est ce que parce que
nous ingurgitons donc des hormones
femmes femelle est ce que nous il y a
des effets secondaires qui se font
ressentir dès le début ou bien sur le
moyen ou le long terme et sk des effets
secondaires indésirables
évidemment comme c'est la première fois
comme c'est les premières pilules il
faut s'attendre à ça nombre d'effets
secondaires et en particulier à
particulier pousse des seins
la pose est ce un peu mais surtout la
prise deux fois et malheureusement ben
oui les familles sont passés nous y
passerons aussi la plus de poids sur le
bas du corps
c'est dire des cuisses et des fesses et
il va falloir bien sûr il va falloir que
nous fassions attention à ce que nous
mangeons et puis et puis les muscles
évidemment ne sont pas très sains ces
petits facettes hormones et en
particulier nos muscles risque de se
féminiser me fais pas trop je vous
rassure
est ce que la taille
de nos attributs risque d'en prendre un
nom nos attributs tu restes triomphant
marqué par pont entre notre sexualité
risque là par contre de décliner
certains hommes ont effectivement
rencontré des problèmes de libido et de
problèmes d'érection
est ce que le système pileux par exemple
sont percés de balles à risque voilà par
exemple on perd ses poils en perd ses
poils
oui non mais écoutez maintenant j'arrête
le cauchemar est terminé olivier c'était
une blague pour matin bonheur c'est nous
sommes ici c'est une date pour matt
appel à moi je le renard est le
cauchemar
oui oui oui voilà elle n'est pas là à
tout non non ça on arrête tout et
nourriture elle n'est pas là elle n'est
pas arrivée
non mais je dois dire que si elle n'est
pas d'arriver oui oui j'ai vu j'ai vu
que tu devenais pas surtout quand tu
m'as dit qu'en plus on allait avoir un
truc un peu d'humour c'est pas
intéressant
en fait si cette pilule n'est pas arrivé
dans nos pharmacies et qu'elle n'est pas
prête d'arriver et bien tout simplement
c'est en raison justement de ces effets
secondaires qui sont évidement très
problématique et surtout aussi parce que
les laboratoires ne font pas beaucoup
d'efforts pour trouver cette pilule dans
la mesure où il y aura sans doute peu de
candidats et même si cette pilule là je
démontrais un cachet d'aspirine
ce cachet d'aspirine si c'est jamie
cette pilule devait arriver aux
pharmacies et bien je dois dire que ce
serait sans doute un bide commercial et
ça c'est un véritable frein dans
l'industrie pharmaceutique lorsqu'on
part sur un bide on ne le fait pas et
puis et puis pour finir je dirais que
les femmes elles-mêmes lorsqu'on les
interroge ne sont pas forcément preneuse
de cette pilule dans la mesure où elle
dit
et vous donner c'est nous qui sommes
enceinte si il ne la prend pas comment
vais-je le savoir je préfère ma sueur et
moi même donc la pilule pour hommes
c'est une arlésienne dont on n'a pas
fini de parler parce qu' elle n'est pas
prêt d'arriver dans nos pharmacies
ben écoute david bravo en tout cas parce
que tu étais très convaincant geismar
j'ai plongé les complètement
[Musique]